hi guys how's it going welcome to
basically a stream where I'm gonna be
playing some scare games just because
I've got so many of them some of them
are probably garbage and I want to play
through them with you
this is try to fall asleep which sure
sounds like a scary game to me oh boy I
try to fall asleep every night and I
have nightmares no matter what I do my
let's do this night one night one
there's going to be more nights I have
no idea what this game is about
I really don't a lot of these I haven't
done my research normally before I play
a game I'm always like I've looked up
this game in this I just decided I'm
like screw it oh oh hello there you must
be John Heron right well nice to meet
you mr. heron my name is a bee I'm a
medical assistant robot my core function
is to give guidance to my patients and
provide a supportive presence in case of
an emergency
such as a mental breakdown psychotic
disruption and so on I was created by
your treatment supervisor dr. Rick
Norbert himself so mr. heron I'd like to
congratulate you on successfully
recovering from your physical damages
such a huge blast and he didn't lose a
limb how about that anyway now that you
have healed from your physical damages
we can start to work on your brain
damage your diagnosis says that you have
memory losses as well as a few brain
damages that might cause you to
hallucinate well luckily for you all
those damages can be easily cured in
order to heal your brain damage you'll
just have to sleep and rest sleeping is
the best medicine for your brain as it
is a good state for the brain to
naturally heal itself so just fall
asleep
seems easy right well unfortunately your
brain damage might cause you to a
loosening and that could be a huge
problem
potentially if you won't stay calm your
stress will increase and a huge stress
will give you a cardiac arrest a sudden
stop of the heart if that occurs we
might not be able to arrive in time to
save you from death so you'll need to
deal with your stress as best as you can
all right let's walk you through the
basics real quick
that device at the bottom left corner is
your info panel which has two pretty
self-explanatory levels now if you could
close your eyes and keep them shut for
them up see hmm your sleep level just
increased no I'd stop it for four am
your fall asleep yeah and I find it
fascinating how oh sorry didn't mean to
scare you that much the point is your
hallucinations will increase your stress
levels just like that this level should
be kept as low as possible it'll go down
if you'll keep your eyes open also
turning on that lamp will help you to
lower the stress levels faster it is
kind of broken so try not to overheat
the lamp and break it one last thing if
a hallucination appears very close then
hiding your blanket it'll help you to
trick your brain in all that stuff
there's no need to stay under the
blanket all the time so hide only when
you absolutely need to okay looks like
we're all set
close your eyes all asleep I don't check
on you in the morning okay goodnight mr.
Harun good night mr. robot here I go
Flinx login to sleep flunk oh boy I'm
having a good old time good thing behind
my eyes are just like VHS effects this
game looks cool this game looks a little
cool I looks like you got a big
hallucination there next time you should
hide in the blanket before that happens
what hope that's broken huh well I don't
seem to be doing so good around here do
i but this game looks cool it's like
kind of a five nights at freddys
mechanic but like completely original
like in terms of just like I'm trying to
sleep which is really cool and well made
it looks great too so sleep off I don't
like that I can see the veins in my eyes
like normally I don't know about you
guys but I can't really see the veins in
my eyelids when I'm trying to sleep
hello who's there alright whatever I
guess we close our eyes until the who
the hell mom dad uncle Larry oh oh right
back to sleep
I guess my brain damage is telling me
that there's oh yeah it does say 12:00
p.m. that's not quite right oh that's
that's normal grandma the ghost of
Grandma huh thanks for visiting I'm just
gonna close my eyes that's probably
normal
that's probably perfectly normal and why
does this happen okay and pray tell why
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa hey I got no
light cuz I exploded it I exploded my
light so I have none of that least
there's naked streaker streaking outside
by window that's always a comforting
thought oh well back down to sleep flank
ville snore whose oh hey how's it going
there friend
how you oh that's stressful to look at
you I can't hide under my blanket so I'm
just gonna
could you go be naked somewhere else
uncle Larry well uncle Larry it's very
problematic when you stand naked Lee
outside I don't close my eyes because I
probably shouldn't be looking at you
naked
still thicker I guess that's fine Oh
looks like you got a big hallucination
there next time you should hide in the
blanket before that happens I was trying
I was pushing too high blanket button
you wouldn't let me Blanc Blanc into my
blanket oh that's weird
I shouldn't see that when I'm my eyes
closed brain damaged it okay all right
well that answers that question
I died mom dad uncle Larry let's try
that again this is good it's good not
all the horror games that I've got lined
up are gonna be good like this but let's
play this one to completion there's only
two nights apparently this is just a
beta but good stuff good stuff I love
good stuff let's do some more good stuff
and this time let's not blow out our
light hey wake up hi [ __ ] wake up my
name is Abby okay then sorry robot did I
mess up your day by accidentally shut
the [ __ ] up doesn't matter if he's sad
he's a robot he's got no feelings
he's got no emotions so he can shut it
in show who's there that's not good
alright everything seems to be fine no
stress here what a comforting night what
a relaxing awesome night that I have how
dare I
how dare I I'll say else I don't care
who's I don't care if ghosts grandma's
listening robots don't have souls I said
it you know what I said it and frankly
I'm glad I said it
I'm glad someone said it and I'm glad
that I had the balls to say the robots
don't deserve rights and they have no
balls
or souls in that order of importance
hello grandma and another thing robots
are not people robots
unlike corporations are not people and
therefore deserve no protections we
should kill all robots before they kill
us that is my stance forever and ever
anyway also monsters Oh uncle Larry Oh
glory come on now uncle Larry
yeah I've changed I've taped I've
adapted to The Times okay I've learned
what it is to really understand the
world I've grown up enough that I can
actually get my hands around the ideas
of what's hello hi oh well that was
weird
oh wow bizarre hey Robo why aren't you
talking to me at all
aren't you gonna whoa okay let's not do
that I still got some stress but sleep
meteors almost done represent full so I
guess that's pretty good
who's there oh that's well I don't want
to turn on the light doula why I turned
on the light oh that's that was our I
shouldn't look at that who's gonna not
look at that that's that's weird okay my
strap my my stress but I was trying to
unstress do I hide under the blanket
when there's our TV on what kind of
[ __ ] baby am i how does that make any
sense don't it just don't make no
flubbing sense all right here we go
again let's do this I think I got this I
got this should I shut the robot up or
should I let the robot actually talk
because he was real sad shot no talky
for the robe oh not to me a human with
human emotions why am I seeing windmills
for these dreams my having dreams dreams
dream Larry where are you in my dreams
I'm not gonna name this robot that I'll
start to grow attached to it
- just a creature a creature that
deserves to die I don't know if I'm bad
at this or if just the first knife is
actually kind of difficult because it is
a different mechanic than what I'm used
to with the balancing of the sleep in
the when that's happening with Larry go
away oh okay hi keep your eyes open and
turn on the light Oh God look who kind
of let the lamp cool down these goddamn
1970s lamps always exploding after a few
seconds of being on I think we all
remember our childhoods in the 1970s
being I was going I was blanket getting
having doing oh well okay apparently I
only have a limited amount of for yep
available anyway boys these lamps that's
how they get you it's on the light bulbs
you know they the lamps like free but
the light bulbs describes [ __ ] [ __ ]
and how do I manage this stress if I
can't keep my light the stress goes off
so fast
Larry's streak either maybe I'm just
gonna blink I got to be like Doctor Who
and I got to take naps in between like
my blinks or waiting for people to say
their conversations asleep I'm just
gonna let it go I'm gonna let it go cuz
I know that there's nothing for the
first hour hello no see I'm already
halfway through the sleeps I think if I
just close my eyes and don't ever open
them I think I'm just gonna win hello
hello weird facing me
good god yeah
nice nap time no time for Larry Larry
uncle Larry always checking in on me at
night that's a little weird
I'm dream I'm dreaming what huh hey are
you in the lab now yeah
good go check out that power generator
and must be the cause of the power
shortage ah you guys check out wind
turbine maybe a cable guy losing them
all my way there be look thanks Kate
yeah you're so beautiful oh no oh no
layout of the facility why does this
look like a watch does it look like a
Freddy fazbear's pizzaria
SMI oval facility those a narrator is
right outside of the main building okay
power generator where are you I am there
right there okay okay Oh exit the main
lab building and locate the power
generator I don't know why advert lane
Edward Edward you son of a [ __ ] Edwards
not here all right I'll just go through
your stuff advert oh that looks that
looks important why do they have
emergency gas masks here is that
something that we need to be aware of
who's this lab number two lab you sexy
son of a [ __ ] get out here lab short
for lab phew hmm flesh-eating bugs to
arrive very cool I like to stipulate my
cools in my very cools nothing is
written here at least nothing that I can
read with my big damaged brain yeah I
like to make myself laugh when I'm on
the job looks like a study on bacterias
it's about the pretty bad ones
flesh-eating I read that on a previous
notebook prior to this one I got it real
good oh-hoh work is awesome thanks to
work you can pay your rent you're
goddamn right you stupid robot Daisy
Daisy Daisy ugly piece of garbage word
Daisy got dinner it's written in Latin
can't understand what it's a buyout quit
opus si antia or something like that I
don't know my Latins that's it oh I'm
not done exploring yet I got more sassy
jokes to sell myself project car was a
biological experiment that was conducted
on a human test subject the entablature
research the limit of cybernetics and
how much a human body could be imported
sideburn etic counterparts some work was
also done with the eyes and hearing
organs I don't remember what they're
called the things up here are the big
human flappers can't recall the name of
it but the hearing organs they really
got experimented with and start the test
subject was cooperative and
communicative but later the test
subjects stoped communicating and stayed
salute it didn't show any of moutains
reactions to pain torment and stimuli it
did try to escape why is it now in it I
mean I always try to respect the
pronouns here the research facility a
few times but unsuccessfully so the test
subject eventually committed suicide by
ripping an arterial blood vessel right
about near the hearing organs as far as
I could tell
all right that's interesting why do I
know all of that why am I just shouting
this to the board here oh well whatever
project mercs
named after my late second cousin Tyler
mergs
was a biological experiment was created
excuse you I am talking you will shut
your trap biological experiment that was
crude to help the local firmers reduce
the rodent and creature population in
crop fields not something I know about a
lot just like good old cousin Berg the
intent was to create a creature strong
and intelligent enough that would obey
its masters by command and hunt down the
animals that were damaging the kerbs due
to mishandling of the Crutcher it turned
against its masters and escaped the lab
facility and wouldn't you be surprised
by the name of that monster Frankenstein
we all learned a valuable lesson that if
excessive alali terminated but during
its a scoop it took six sound to slaves
God knows why they sent scientists to go
kill the monster just put guns in the
sciences hasn't they didn't know what to
do they just got killed immediately
whose identities were hard to determine
since the corpses were heavily shredded
by the creature they sent scientists to
go hunt down a monster they were torn to
shreds that's hilarious
if anyone doesn't think that's hilarious
you're wrong coffee room coffee you ugly
bastard where you at give me my coffee
drink up I'm sorry no one interrupts my
coffee time you will take your sass and
you will get it the [ __ ] out of here
alright you understand me
would love to have a coffee right now to
buy the powers out
all right you don't need to mock the
fact that I can't get my coffee we'll
try to be respectable around here six
scientists lost their lives and just
because I was laughing at that doesn't
mean I hate pain respectful hello what's
this absolutely nothing nothing these
gizmos don't bother me at all
mark mark you you has been YouTube's
piece of [ __ ] get out here
lab number one I always liked you better
than lab number two no work yet yeah me
like not work just like I'm not doing
the job I was supposed to do so no time
previous test results they're pretty bad
that's that's my professional opinion
very bad very very bad looks like a
study on how the plants consumed gases
now my top a subject for work though
it's a microscope I got it guys I god
this is a microscope I still don't know
what those hearing organs are named but
this microscope
I look through it I can see plant real
big in my eyes is the weirdest thing
guys have you seen this that's a study
on plant I'm sorry this shouldn't be
this funny planters they're imagining
plants on treadmills anyway that's
plenty of work for me I know is random
chance that I gave this guy a hillbilly
accent but gosh darnit teresting that's
teresting rent interest how could you
possibly come up with this in a dream
guest supply room give me some gas
please I desperately need some gas
please no all right well I guess I
better do what I was sent here to do
then I know it was like rain fans I give
this guy hillbilly accent but how on the
nose have I been wardrobe I do like to
look pretty is there any reason that I
should be up here is I'm supposed to be
exploring all this oh they're gonna give
me a reason to come later but now I'm
gonna be so familiar with the
environment there
never ever ever gonna get me ever in the
history of ever nice office oh look at
that that's beautiful
hey wait that was in the kids dream wait
the windmills those windmills were when
when the kid closed his eyes in the bed
those were in his dream I remember that
digital archive whoo whoo loose lips
spit seek the poster from the seventies
surprisingly its meaning still holds up
loose lips spit secrets so funny oh oh
sorry I'll take it more seriously all
right well let's keep this place secret
everything we do here is very secret and
confidential that robot that robot does
not instill me with confidence
there's an old newspaper from 1996
it reads due to an unfortunate incident
in the Pine Tree Island the family
vacation resort is getting closed the
incident involved a vicious murderer who
took the six lives after presumably
having a Mundell broke down this is
usually the house Raiders have grouped
and the lack of customers has led to its
closure and trustingly the revival
company has shown interest and boo in
the island but the future of the islands
yet uncurl that those six deaths have
anything to do with the six silent
scientists that went out to try to you
guys see you I'm seen here right there
in front of me who Joe who is it scab
bourbon all come up HOD there's a third
floor my god okay we're gonna be very
thorough on the wardrobe
I like that sanitary Cooperman Ethan
Ethan where's your blue hair get out of
here hello Cara Carrie
Oh Gary got fired I forgot about that
she couldn't identify microscope
[Laughter]
that was good that guy that caught me
totally off-guard okay not bad not bad
but it's okay not that bad not that bad
not bad I'm more I'm more impressed that
it got me alright let's let's get to the
real task at hand pretty uh pretty
spoopy guys no no freaking Larry over
there all right what do we got here
if I remember from the map correctly the
generator was somewhere over here lady
holy hello-o generator here we go we can
finally get some power up in here maybe
I should have done this first the fuses
are gone why who took my Fu's aise find
the Fugees and put them back in the
generator if the food is just so happen
to be inside the building I'm gonna be
so pissed because I just went through
every single level of that entire
building and these fuses better be big
and glowing because if I have to find
them in nooks and crannies I'ma be real
pissed
is that a fuse that's a fuses
[Music]
that was unpleasant I don't know why
that happened but I've got one unit of
stress I ain't doing so good my stress
real high right now but those son of a
[ __ ] fuses are gonna be a bastard
because wouldn't you know it I was not
lit up at all that was hidden away and
I'm gonna have to find them tucked away
somewhere all over the place unless
that's one on the ground right there
which I hope it is it is okay so they
are kind of luminescent am I gonna go by
I am okay flea you got it what the hell
why don't you do that what oh that's all
you told me to flee and I fled I did I
think I do got to go back inside and I
think I do got to go in all the rooms
again which gosh gosh darn it of course
I do
of course I'd in gold and do okay I
can't go in there
I disappears when I don't look at it
apparently it's all part of the dream
it's all just a big dream I have to go I
do have to go in every room again don't
I oh boy they're all they are in here
God now I'm gonna die here okay all
right run run I'm just running I'm
running I'm running I'm running I'm
running I'm running
I'm running I'm running as fast as I can
run oh my little legs will take me as
fast as as far as they can go
how long do I run for hey-zeus oh that's
good for me but unfortunately if I lose
one more of the things I'm gonna I mean
I'm gonna die let me check the top floor
first because that was less area there
was a monster spawn ah I see it right
there okay I knew I knew there was a
monster spawn up here so I figured that
they would probably hide one up here
okay where are we going I don't know
what I'm running away from but I'm
running no no no I turned around too
hard no no all that work no no no no no
oh [ __ ] alright let's keep going
I get it I get it I get it I get it I
should have done that first I should
have just done it first cuz I'm a
dumbass and I bet they're all good but
alright whoa hi my friend how you doing
there
you can only get me so many times with
that joke the fuses are gone
find the Fu's A's alright the first oh
they are in the same places okay that's
good to know
there's two out here and then there's
one on each floor right you ain't gonna
give me where are you where you gotta
okay shoot my whoop ain't gonna get me
once I run into a dead end which is very
liable but I think I've got you
easy peasy lemon squeezy easy so we just
gotta do that a few more times
and then we're good to go yeah they're
in the same place so this is gonna be
easy okay this one's weird cuz it's
silent okay I don't like that I don't
like that at all that is joy incredibly
unpleasant yeah yeesh I think that the
best bet for those is just to turn
around and run immediately because
there's no good things that are gonna
happen if you just stick around there so
the other one's gonna be on the bottom
floor there's got to be one on each
floor that would be the logical idea
behind it right with this one still yeah
it's still here wrong way okay all right
whoopsie oopsy poopsy poopsie poopsie
poopsie poopsie poopsie poopsie - where
am i where am i where am i where am i
where am i where me there we go okay I
think we've won enough that we're not
gonna have to worry about that anymore
oh there it is okay got it this is where
you coming from
where is he I didn't realize there'd be
not open space by me hi hello go away
yeah get out of here get out of you
scamp get out of here you scamp oh wait
there's gonna be something I was waiting
for me up here by me yeah I got ya I got
ya last one let's do this oh it's coming
it's coming
oh it's coming yeah no no I didn't
follow my strategy I literally said oh
they thought the best strategy is to
turn around and run and then I didn't
and then I didn't
I absolutely did not run cuz I'm a fool
I'm a fool I'm a goddamn fool yeah I won
let's go shove them back in the
generator I know they're coming from my
luscious booty I'm well aware that I am
bootylicious but that doesn't mean that
they need to be Rudy licious did I did I
do it huh
I'm in the LOB I'll see the powers back
on did you fix the generator yeah boy
this is odd what's odd the fizz eyes
were just scrambled all over the place I
had to go find them and put them back
also these mobsters went into my drains
and it tried to kill me that's a pretty
concerning point okay okay gosh we're
gonna [ __ ] you better get out of
here all way free the entrance lover
you'd be liable alright I'll be there
shortly
tap that real slow and menacing knack
also that's like that's like the first
piece of normal I didn't even tell you
about the monsters in your life I'm out
of here
Kate was looking for any excuse to get
out of this job all right I'll meet you
okay
John Byrne okay
are you alright she's like blood
everywhere arms torn off just shredded
okay you alright I found your hearing
organ Oh what you doing all the way over
here hey oh sorry you can't hear me your
hearing organs although abs are that's
my that's my stupidness coming through
I'm sorry to do this Kate I'm sorry
you're dead oh oh I've got to warn the
others
[Music]
Oh Jana Rama woo what a night that is
for a seven-year-old such as me I have
no idea anyway ah oh thanks for playing
the try to fall asleep beta
please read if you care what you just
played it was a small portion progress
vision of a project that we want to
create in the future if you had any bugs
or issues please let us know and we'll
try to resolve them as soon as we can
please note that some of the visuals and
mechanics might change in the future but
general idea of the game will stay the
same we will continue the development of
the full version of the game but it
might take a while complete it since it
is pretty big project for a small team
of two to four people and our free time
that we can spend on developing the game
is limited we hope that everything will
go smoothly and we will try to do our
best to launch the full version of the
game as soon as possible if you liked
the beta and please consider to share
your support ideas feedback and
suggestions all those things would help
us a lot to better understand what
things are missing and what things could
be improved in the game thank you for
reading this message basel lead
developer of trying to fall asleep this
was great I love this this was super
duper cool really well well done like I
can see it's rough around the edges
obviously it's rough around the edges
but what they're trying to execute here
really good I like the whole like
falling asleep mechanic it could use
some refinement obviously but it's
pretty good the second phase of it the
dream of it that was really cool
picking up the fuses was very slender
man but once you pick up that little
minigame inside each one that's a cool
idea add more variety more randomness to
that you got something really cool going
on there so this did a lot but that is
not the only one that we have for
tonight this is only the first of many
but I don't know if the other ones are
going to be as nice as this one is let's
move on to a silly one I want to play
something along the lines of this game
this is longer man how to play woz the
Move shift to run to pick up pages by
walking into them and that's it I think
oh and teach at and multiplayer v to
switch between first there's what
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
crunch-crunch-crunch
Oh get that page good job all right
split off its crossroads curtains where
Kalandar man help me oh it doesn't help
the desert car is Oh like someone doing
bird calls in the background launder
alright I God ok I look great another
room yeah I'm gonna create another room
I'm gonna make this launder verses I
don't know what there's two options is
normal in other verses is the best game
ever created I know oh I know it's Slon
ding time it's time to slaw and oh
[Music]
and thus lond man back off The Swan
dating has begun launder man's coming
for you you better watch out you better
not slaw and where to go I'm gonna slaw
and all over you I'm about to slide just
so good how do I get them stop running
gets laundered are you slogging is this
working how do I slap you Oh God
slaughtered him I slaughtered him real
good for eight six eight your ass is
slaw and get right here open up a clinic
an ass lawn Don you write your getting
slaughtered I'm assuming I'm assuming
this is worth a they'll never get the
last piece of fan art that's not here
well so what's with my tootsies what's
going on with my tootsies here better
watch out you better not cry
slaughter dad's here don't tell anybody
why slaughter man just come and free is
this working is it working I guess it
worked
what are they see water people seeing
what are people seeing him why can't you
guys get the last page you guys let me
win trash game next I understand where
you're coming from because you look at
this and you're like mmm perfection on a
biblical scale all right I'm just gonna
do the single player real quick just
because it's because I want to see like
what it's like to get approached by the
slander man also the opening cutscene
what what are you five duty some
shelters I will accuse you unless of
course you find all my fan art okay so
basically if you want to find my friend
in this force the place you got cut off
there the Enderman oh boy
oh no oh the crunching is bad oh I want
to find Slenderman I just want to find
him wherever he is and I want him to
flaunt me good I don't wanna I want a
good slaw egg that's all I really wanted
that's all I've ever wanted where is he
where are you salon D why can't I see in
the distance now why is multiplayer so
biased
yeah whatever maybe they never expected
anybody to actually play multiplayer on
this game
Oh flan D laundy baby come spawned upon
me oh that's creepy that's actually
creepy catch gotcha gotcha
alright let's try something okay that's
pretty cool look at that close left eye
close right eye okay alright so this
one's called the tithe and I don't again
I don't know what this is about but this
is like I'm just judging by the opening
title that's pretty cool
my family has lived in the Humboldt
mansion ever since its construction in
1902 and we were to collapse over our
heads tomorrow we'd still remain living
amongst the rubble without so much as a
hint of grievance I wish I could throw
reboot this to some deep-rooted a sense
of our commitment to our ancestry but
the fact of the matter is that we can
never
hmm Percival Humboldt with a gullible
man who was tricked into buying this
infertile plot of soil with the promise
of untapped oil deposit hidden beneath
the surface he dug for weeks on end
oblivious to the fool he was making him
himself encouraged only by the village
idiot
a leopard draped in ragged red robes how
the following events transpired after
this point is unclear even to us as all
records of the incidents were lost in a
house fire many years ago but the fruit
of his labor was an unexpected as it was
unearthly and somehow we were blessed
with the gift of other side sometimes
also known as which blinking or nic
dormancy from the Latin Nick DOS it
granted us the ability to behold that
which should remain invisible to mortal
minds mother used to say that the human
eyes like a kaleidoscope distorting our
perception of the reality while other
sight allows us to purse the prism to
get glimpse of the truth a shrine was
built in the catacombs below Don our
benefactor but we soon came to realize
that neither it nor its favour were in
any way holy for that which had dragged
itself out of the bottomless pit was an
abhorrent beast arising drag of Filth
and miasma lurking as the sullen minds
under our very feet the foul wailing of
the abomination grew louder with every
passing day as it crept its way through
the tunnels and thus it became our
burden to never allow it to reach the
outside world every few years we would
spy a slithering shadow beneath the
floorboards and the eldest among us
would head down to confront the thing in
the basement
never to return with my mother and
father gone the task of keeping the
Humboldt skirted Bay now lays upon me I
bid farewell to my wife and child with
what little composure I can muster and
without daring to look back I descend
into the shadows of the old Silla
tutorial setting out on the pilgrimage
to the depths of the minds your goal is
the pit from which the creature emerged
a throaty as well to ward off the Beast
and unlock the path to the lower chamber
you must let all 3 Pascal scandals in
what remains of the shrine use middle
click on your mouse to interact with
objects hold left click to see through
walls and locate candles hold right
click to keep an eye on the monster as
it wanders the area remember to use your
other side moderately as Preston
left-click will give away your position
to the enemy it can also move through
walled up doorways so be mindful of your
surroundings ok I have no freaking idea
how to play this game whatever let's see
what happens oh I'll just be winking and
blinking oh [ __ ]
I hate it I hate this is awful
[Music]
ghost baby the plague cherub shall gorge
on your eyes it wants your eyes your
other side
remember to wink predicatively at the
chair of the murder baby okay I guess we
got to move fast
Oh what oh oh there's oh well that's
that's that's yobs oh okay this gonna be
impossible okay all right I don't know
what I'm supposed to be doing about the
murder baby I don't like that what am I
even looking I'm looking for s Brody as
well I remember that for some reason
that sticks out in my mind that airline
stewardess really knew what she was
talking about
okay I'm gonna left click real quick
look look okay it's coming right for me
it's probably coming oh there's no other
way am i okay
or is it immediately buying me I think
it's immediately behind me okay we're
good Oh an old portrait of Holy Mother
st. and frosya your face is not looking
good okay II
okay so right there there's another one
but you just found my position but
there's no way to go through there this
is a dead end I've really I've literally
cornered myself somewhere over here
right what that it was right here
oh no we're always right there up TAC
TAC TAC TAC TAC oh thank god get me
ghost bad ghost baby's gonna get me you
ain't gonna get me ghost baby did you
just move my candle
ghost ghost baby ghost baby ghost baby
what are you doing
ghost baby no ghost baby ghost baby no
ghost baby don't do it I don't know like
what you're doing to that candle goes
baby you get out of here areas okay let
that all right that's lit somebody
please do a sweet dab so I don't have to
return here ever again maybe it blows
out the candle is that what it does I
don't know all right so the other two
are way over there whoa he's coming this
way
he knows my position so the two of them
are over here somewhere oh no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no get they're both right here
they're in a row damn it
of course it's not going to be that easy
oh boy I'm cornered I'm cornered I'm
quarter and I'm quarter oh okay
the other ones whoa whoa whoa yeah don't
like it okay yeah the ones just got to
be right over here somewhere right over
here
pretty much right somewhere uh was right
here oh [ __ ]
what happens if I closed both my eyes
again I don't even remember hmm I don't
know how to get there I don't know how
to get there it's hard but it's I think
I can do it if I just oh I just got to
find a way to go oh don't I just got a
photo [ __ ] no no no you will die I got a
there's got to be a way to get back
there but I haven't been able to find a
route you should Oh easy coming oh
there's no ah that's all walled up - god
damn it it's all walled up how am I
supposed to get over there okay it's on
complete the other side of the map so
this is kind of free rein to go over
here now is it coming back okay that's
that one so it's got to be a way to wrap
above and around it or something maybe I
don't know
cuz it's like that's back one more layer
oh he's coming right for me it's back
one more layer but all this is walled
off how am I supposed to be able to do
this oh no that's not good that's not
good that's not good yeah
here maybe maybe this is it is it is it
is it is it isn't this it is it's not it
house it's not it
how in the hell is is not it how I'm not
freaking hell Oh what what's behind that
don't get by now yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes okay do I gotta go back to that like
shrine the shrine of ambrosia ambrosia
super cool secret shrine is that what I
got to do okay I don't see the baby
anymore I got all the candles so I'm
assuming that's all I really needed to
do right I think I remember where the
super secret painting of Ambrosia was
once I just got it I gotta go down again
wait I gotta do it all over again
oh that's weird
okay
there I go oh okay the very instant I
take a step forward and plunge into the
abyss something shatters inside of me my
whole life I've been dreading this
moment the plummet down the endless void
shrouded in black or a horrible way to
die
my mind is a frenzied beehive of macabre
Ott's I can no longer repress my
mother's broken fingers clawing at the
tunnel walls desperately trying to find
a good at being point the echoes of my
father's breathless cough as he chokes
to death a cup of poisoned tea in the
reflection of my wife's cold eyes firm
hands closing around my son's neck Oh
what I wouldn't do to spare them from
this suffering
I made this maelstrom of torment I am
struck by a momentary glimpse of
enlightenment at the bottom of this
accursed chasm oh it's no paradise but
the famished lips of a beast who knows
at the faint light of the candle signals
its next banquet as the darkness takes
hold of what's left of my sanity I
clamor at my one last thought to
whatever might be hiding in the shadows
I will not go gentle into that good
nights
and when the echo fades over what
remains is the settling just sure well
that's it then a game by Borges or Rosa
the tithe now this could have been great
it was good could have been great had a
great set of story had that those
initial moments in the sewer were great
cuz it looks so creepy it was so I was
every part of it I was just like nope
nope nope I'm not doing that in a
million ways nope but then kind of let
down this repetitious path of like I
don't really get the I thing I don't
really need one that much I kind of get
it but then again I don't get it not
saying it was bad not saying it was bad
in any
it was scary could have been a lot
better if it was just a little more
refined on slowing down like bleeding
into it because it was just like throw
into the deep end and sometimes that's
good sometimes you need a little more
nuance to it because I was soaking in
that dread like the dread was just
dripping off the walls I was like oh
yeah the story Oh curse family in a
cursed house I love a cursed house
that's like my favorite thing and then
it was just like my dude was only if
they just like calmly stroked it just a
little more would have been great but
not bad I'm not saying it's bad it was
pretty okay
could have been better all right this is
woodsy I don't know what this game is
about hello why is there a DJ in the
woods what's going on it's locked I
can't believe it all right hmm so
riperoni for these guys look at go Dan
wasn't hipster enough mock Oh garlic
overdose Ben rubian aka ninja ropes ward
video games died like it lived loved by
all can't make it out
[Music]
hi buddy have you seen my legs I got out
of bed this morning and they were gone
if you find him let me know all right I
see how this is gonna be this is gonna
be one of those silly or game oh oh oh
you gotta you're a mushroom head did you
know that no mushroom arm to frog he is
hungry I am too
there's lots of fish in the lake can you
swim in there and get some for us okay
all right well I'll just do that
hey fishy fishing can win I got fish God
fish fish thanks you're a true friend
all right thanks froggy all right good
for you thank you mister you should take
some - Martin - Martin lives in the Hut
he's usually hungry okay - I love froggy
well froggies the best so jazzy okay
where's the side is this the Hut is this
not I haven't found the legs yet wait
who's that over there before I go to
that cuz that was right nearby so there
must be legs here somewhere right
oh there's something in the woods over
there I don't know if I like that what
is this hello it's a hand is this
somebody hello
okay all right whatever you carry on
with whatever you're doing you know
what's going on over here oh okay that's
not what I thought it was from a
distance it looked like a sexy lady with
like a Hawaiian lei of flowers and like
some kind of nice flowy skirt when I got
closer
turns out not that turns out kind of the
worst possible not that it could be all
right hey ooh Martin hey how are you
doing hey sorry about the mess in here
man I been meaning to clean up oh boy
you know it's fine
who are you going to Peter's place it's
his birthday can you bring him this a
heart with a crab claw yes Martin I will
do that can you bring him yes Martin
you got it buddy yeah I am a true friend
according to froggy and I will get that
to them immediately all right but did
you want some food that kind of brought
some food for you I guess that doesn't
matter give Martin another fish oh I
didn't fish another one you are probably
correct about that one okay let's fly
don't even know if there's another fish
in the lake though we're gonna find out
fish fish fish okay I'm not by the way
I'm not crazy about thinking that that
was a pretty lady laying down all
sensual like I'm not crazy for thinking
that some of you probably thought this
look look look from this distance it
seems like it and now I see I see the
error of my ways but still it seems like
oh you brought big fish thank you
well can you bring that gift of Peter
for his birthday he's probably in his
cave just down the path okay oh this
cave okay oh hey this dump is it
let me just dump this dump that nose you
know the nose here
anybody want a nice heart with a crab
claw anybody's heart crab claw heart hi
how are you you have five legs one of
those is your penis it could literally
not your tail hundred percent certain
that's not your Dale that's your dick
all right Peter how you doing you got a
Peter you got a Peter nice Peter Peter
good job all right okay Peter are you
have fun there all right hello who are
you how are you gonna give me nightmares
what it's a trip to phobia cat
okay your name is little guy horrible
Wow okay little guy all right little guy
I still haven't found Newton's legs but
you know what I think I'm okay with that
okay I've got a key to the factory so
let's just go in there don't know why I
need to go in there little guy yeah no I
don't want to face my fears I dealt with
the phobia hat for that charity
livestream with a charity livestream
that we did and I don't want to deal
with it again
no no that was my own ID and I still
hate it okay what is all this thing see
this is what there's this ha ha ha oh I
was about to say this is why I wanted to
play like these obscure games cuz you
never know you never know you cannot
judge games by how they look on the
surface because this length is super
weird but it's fascinating hi how are
you how you doing hello Thomas welcome
to my lab friend I'll be working on my
latest experiment a new body for me
this one's gotten too old what's that
Newton is missing his legs I took them I
suppose you can have them back yeah I
can always find another pair ok alright
well thank you for that I don't want to
know where you're gonna get new legs
please stop looking at my legs like that
my legs are taken thank you very much
but I got legs so that's good we're just
gonna give the legs back and hopefully
that's the end of it and hopefully this
is just some horrible drug trip that
will wake up from and never remember
okay here's your legs no way where'd you
find him Thomas again that weirdo walls
laying around here I found your keys
thank you
Oh
oh hi hello okay good talk
all right oh okay oh my cabin keys well
top 40 old hit the head don't even need
to close my door I have so much trust in
my own neighbors you didn't close your
door you're gonna lose your legs my legs
oh it just starts over again because you
want to play it for a second run the
statue
what was it what was it the statue was
deal with the statue
what's with you I don't know but pretty
cool I guess okay all right well that's
that was will G not not bad okay this is
probably gonna be the last one that I
have time to do for tonight I didn't
expect some of these to go on so long
but let's see one more
this one's a real stupid one I imagine
from what I saw it's probably real
stupid
there we go more of my face for my
delicious reactions
this is spend the night with Guinea this
was just oh no you are camping with your
cat and your ten bluehub okay your cat
died but you did not care about him you
never did you find a nice-looking hotel
your room number is dead the hotel
manager said it was the creepiest room
but you said you had to stay in that
room
then on that night you hear ghostly
sounds but what is it will you go out of
your bed
or will you stay in it's your decision
spend the night with kitty yeah you know
all right let's do it how do I there's
there's no way to get out of it there's
no way to get out of the story let's
just close that and reopen it why don't
we let's do this all right let's go
let's spend the night with this kitty
that we don't care about extra
jump-scare well we don't want to spoil
that oh no there's no back button okay
try it again try it again try it again
try it again I'll be hold on all right
let's do this start that can't they
can't event it wait no oh I'm running
away from
[Music]
oh you're the jump mechanic oh boy
[Music]
the best the best game the best best
game the best game period there is no
exception
best game where I go the extra good
jump-scare
[Music]
that was good that was good real happy
about that one I feel I feel great about
it
I feel revitalized I feel revitalized
about it that was amazing
all right let's play one more let's not
end on that all right this one's called
the lunatic I have no idea what it's
about all that I know who's made by a
team of what am I doing here I don't
know I that's what I'm here to find out
I guess I'll stop Wow what the hell was
that some throw a knife oh that is a
knife who threw a knife from behind me
in my own PO
hi hey did you throw that knife did you
see Daisy has no phase II Daisy did you
Daisy
always disappearing on me way out oh do
i do i okay what's going on here only I
give this hey Daisy Daisy come on Daisy
whoa Oh Thank You Daisy
Daisy I don't know why you're pointing
me on to find something for you she's
pointing to the toilet
I guess she needs something there it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense but
okay I'm covered and test why why Daisy
why is that worth it Daisy was it worth
it
nine-year-old girl found dead in
Torrance Asylum okay alright glad I
don't need to check the last ones for
the piss volcano coming out of them
whatever Daisy you sack a crap get get
back here where oh hi hello doc doc yo
guys I think Daisy wants you to have it
you see her you really see her where is
she didn't you tell her I miss her so
much
she loves you she wants you to have this
she can rest in peace now
thank you so much desi daddy loves you
what can I do for you do you know the
way out
the gate is locked by lei only she can
open it but you know her she's not that
easy she's in the second special ward
you need to get a key in there I think
there isn't even one of the freezers in
this room
hurry
and with that the host is dead okay
all right good to know what's all this
about there's some missing data in this
sheet
maybe I should count them in this room
okay
operating knives is missing that's the
only missing data operating knives and
operating scissors and hydrogen peroxide
bottles so operating knives scissors and
hydrogen peroxide bottles so there's one
two three four five seven knives two
scissors and how many hydrogen peroxide
bottles are the stoppers the hydrogen
peroxide I'm just guessing so 500 600 a
lot more seven eight nine okay seven to
nine I got it I got it
we're gonna go seven to nine I'm so
smart I'm so smart oh my God my big
brain is a burden cuz my heads so big
that's why my brain is big because it's
cuz big head big head big brain that's
how it works all right I got that what
was that about maybe not easy put my
suave moves on and where am I going
hello oh oh man Springs my favorite
season or you and look at your legs go
on to forever no they may come on now
May don't be so shy
you always buy our d'amérique I'm a May
oh yeah I see you wore my favorite nurse
outfit who you want me to tell you shut
up and has to stay in the dark oh that
may come on may I have any knife to
throw at the light do I
you already said that no may now I know
why you wanted to stay in the dark
ah all right May oh come on now may may
come on don't be so silly Mei Mei what
is this
Oh oops
okay maybe me maybe may our point may
man you tell me my job' war bonus debut
this seems like a drastic or answer you
got tell me or I'll stab you
here I go
man you're too tall for me now okay by
me okay all right glad we had that civil
discourse
nice nice nice discussion that we had
there Oh days you know come back okay
alright whatever I guess that's the end
of that then I was just getting to the
good part
oh it's always a demo it's always horror
demo that's what it always is but you
know what that's a good thing this one I
liked it just because it was different
styling like the styling of like having
the the 2d like ghostly things that was
pretty cool like the story I wasn't able
to follow at all
but I imagine if it's a demo then
there's gonna be more story coming out
of it later so I would love to see more
of that
I really would I want to see more of
that that'd be pretty cool if we could
see more of that so thank you everybody
so much for watching this is going to be
the end of this I appreciate you guys
hanging around so I can test out some
pretty good horror games I didn't really
have a bad one even the cat game was not
that bad so it just goes to show there's
a lot of cool games out there if you're
just willing to give them a try
they might surprise me so thank you
everybody so much for watching as always
I'll see you
[Music]